now the vaccine task force was set up to
identify and
buy vaccines can you explain exactly
what your job is now having
done that what why does it seem like
you're going to be here
perhaps even in perpetuity
let's hope not perpetuity but um so um
it was set up as you say to procure
vaccines which we did last year
and then i have to say i took over from
kate bingham who did a tremendous job
and thought well i'm just going to help
soft land all the vaccines now get them
there ready for the public to have
in their arms and then these variants
started emerging and although they're
not dangerous at the moment
they are a threat they're an emerging
threat and therefore
i was asked to work with the task force
again and re-energize it to look to see
how we treat those variants and there's
plenty of
scope to do that so it's nothing to be
alarmed about but it means that we need
to be around a little bit longer
and certainly get get through the next
winter and possibly a bit beyond
so the vaccines task force lives on
trying to help identify ways of getting
vaccines that tackle the new variants
yes and i think we've always thought
that
this virus now is here to stay in some
form but like flu virus but in a form
then we just get to live with them we
don't think of it as
so dangerous and it doesn't kill people
because we got vaccines for them but
that that being said we expect
to move from being a task force to being
normal business at some point where it's
just what the health system does
but we're not ready for that just yet
now i think a lot of the country is
wondering
what to prepare for what the landscape
looks like
do you think that we're still on course
web for a rollout where
every adult gets two doses of either
oxford astrazeneca or pfizer could you
be in a situation
of mixing and matching between the two
because you just started a trial to
study that
uh and once people have had two vaccines
will there then be a booster
this autumn or perhaps every autumn
i think i'm not involved in the policy
making about the vaccine
the vaccination that's done by the
government using the
device of what's called the jcvi
but the likelihood is i would say that
we will we'll roll out this vaccine to
most adults
um before before we finish with the
first first round
and then we're currently studying
whether
to boost that response so what we don't
know about these vaccines at the moment
the ones that have been rolled out is
how long the immunity lasts for now we
won't know that until we've had the
length of time
to test it so we have to be ready in
case it doesn't last long enough to
boost again so
if we need to we'll be ready to boost as
soon as we need to maybe in the winter
and then on top of that the we know that
the variant strains
the vaccines work against but they work
against better if there's a good immune
response a high level of antibody
so if we need to boost for that reason
we'll do it for that reason as well
you're presumably studying all the data
about the vaccines as it comes in and
live global experiment and this changes
week by week
what can you tell us right now about the
infect the effectiveness of vaccines
you know can we now say that infections
declining faster
in the vaccinated compared to the
unvaccinated for certain
you you can never say for certain until
you've got all the data in but
all of the signs are incredibly
encouraging it's looking like these
vaccines are doing exactly what we
expect infections rates are going down
hospitalizations are going down and
people are remaining
i wouldn't say virus freaks we don't
know that but we know that they're not
getting serious disease
and that's what we chat that's what we
were trying to do the important thing is
if you think about the flu vaccine flu
vaccine doesn't stop everybody getting
flu
but it stops it being a severe disease
and it stops people dying you remember
that flu
has been a pandemic it has killed people
and quite viciously killed a lot of
people so
we've got over that one now we we work
with the
disease and and it's fine we live with
it and the health systems
deal with it we'll want to do the same
with this vaccine with this virus
now you've talked about effectively
making a library
of the sequencing of the virus i was
hoping you could just
tell me a little bit about what that is
and
the motivation for doing that is to
speed up
the production and approval of new
vaccines that might tackle
new variants um does that mean that you
could end up
producing new vaccines that help tackle
better new variants incredibly quickly
yes that's that's the aim so if you take
flu as an example again because we have
a lot of learning from flu and we
understand it
the manufacturers of flu have all of the
various uh
variants that come through each year
they have them in store they stop they
store them in a
it's not a library because it's actually
live virus and then they
go from there to making vaccines um the
thing that's come through
in the last year is how fantastic the
mrna technology is
so rna is just a little piece of genetic
code that
that codes for the protein that you want
an immune response to
it's called messenger rna because the
body is got
millions of them in the body all the
time making messages making proteins
that normally keep you alive and well so
all we do is we put
that message in it makes the spike
protein from the virus the body says oh
i don't like this
makes an antibody which makes an immune
response what we can do is we can make
whatever the the changes to that spike
protein that occur
in the mutations in the strain the
variants that come along
we can make all those and we can keep
them store them we store those
those those strains ready those viruses
rna
vaccines ready and soon as we think
there's one that might have broken
through our vaccine
armament we can start a clinical study
and we can get it
into the clinic and then out into
people's arms in a very fast time
there are i think people are interested
in just how fast you might be able to do
some of this
stuff there are people in government who
talk about the extraordinary achievement
of this sequencing library meaning that
you could get a situation when
you have a new variant and then you
could have a new
vaccine to tackle it and approved maybe
it
as quickly as within 40 days does that
sound about the time scale that you
could end up producing new vaccines for
new variants
i think you could get you could get to
40 days to having it tested in the
clinic and know it works and then you've
got to manufacture it as well so the
manufacturing will take another period
of time but
because you wouldn't manufacture huge
amounts before you knew it work hold on
so you know it is a short period of time
it's not like waiting a year like we did
this time
for a new vaccine we know it would work
we do a very small test in
a short test in the clinic and then away
we go
so just spell it out so from the day one
where a new variant
comes along you could have it tested and
approved on day 40 and then manufactured
in people's arms a few weeks later
i think 40 would be a real stretch but
we'd aim for something
as good as that but certainly within 60
days and then
and then after that we would start the
manufacturing and that process takes a
while but
depending on how many doses you're
making wow so just within
i don't know 10 10 weeks or less you
could have
well certainly certainly within three to
four months you would have
a vaccine rather than what we currently
had which was nine to ten months or
maybe even a year
you've advanced purchased i think it's
350 million
doses of the vaccine and we've got the
various companies
astrazeneca fisa madonna uh delivering
in a just-in-time supply line kind of
way uh what they've promised
um are they delivering it at the moment
broadly at the rate that they promised
it
do we expect that to continue from
everything that you can see and
everything that you're monitoring
yeah so the thing that everybody needs
to recognize is the manufacturing of
acting is a very complex process
and predicting before you've made your
first batch how quickly you'll make it
and how many
is really difficult but i can say that
the moment we're very confident that the
manufacturers are doing a brilliant job
they're delivering vaccine at the rate
we require and we will be able to
vaccinate our
population at the rate we required uh
there were some worries
particularly from the devolved
administrations that that might slow
down a bit in the coming
weeks are there any grounds from where
you sit to be particularly
no i think that that might be logistics
that they want to vaccinate
populations that haven't been vaccinated
in that cohort in different places so
they're not
pushing more vaccine out to areas that
have already done that but
that so i think it's just logistics of
where you put the vaccine
i don't it's nothing to do with supply
how much visibility in the future have
you got so
can you be confident about supply uh
at the rate that you were promised it
you know for the next three months for
instance
the next six months definitely we we're
we're confident within the
vaccine task force now that the supply
we're going to get will take us to the
position where we can vaccinate as many
people as the uk wants to vaccinate
so the vaccine task force that's an
incredible achievement so the vaccine
task force knows that it can
secure supply within roughly what time
frame
every adult two jabs of the coronavirus
vaccine
well i think we're probably talking
august sort of time always september
time
all done maybe maybe sooner if we need
to
so how can you be so sure that all of
the
doses will come on time is that because
they're all being manufactured in the
united kingdom
because the manufacturers tell you that
it's get the process is going well
and that you know that they have all the
component parts how how how can you
just forgive me for being curious how
can you be so confident
we're confident because we took a
portfolio approach so
the ones that have been rolled off the
line at the moment they're doing very
well now of course they could have a
manufacturing problem like
you do with any manufacturing of
anything but with vaccines being more
complicated they could have a problem
but because we've taken a portfolio
approach we've got other vaccines that
are going to be approved
in the very near future and once they're
approved we've got those as backups so
pretty confident that it's a low it's a
very low risk that we wouldn't have
vaccine
and that sort of august september that's
two days is not not just one for the
whole adult population
yeah we've got to we've got to deliver
just over 100 million doses of vaccine
and
i i believe we should be able to do that
but i'm not in deployment so i can't
look at the numbers of when there will
be but
if they need to be deployed by then
we've got the vaccine to do it
now i've heard you say that you can
deliver the doses so long as the
government doesn't get
particularly over excited with uh with
its target
i have to say government targets do you
seem rather conservative
i was at a vaccine center just earlier
today where they did
cohorts one to four of the jcvi group
by the end of january and they're
already on cohort six
and they say that they could do cohorts
one to nine so everybody over 50
by the end of march if you guys can
supply
the vaccine does that seem realistic
could you get them the vaccine so that
parts of the country could do all one to
nine by the end of march well
it would be a very logistically that'd
be quite difficult because you'd have to
be saying to other groups that can't do
it quite that fast that you can't
vaccinate the
higher priority group so we have to do
it evenly
and um you know i believe that the rate
we're doing it
now is it's everybody's got used to it
now it's
a phenomenal number of people it's
phenomenal
we've already vaccinated more people
than than you're vaccinating a flu
campaign in
in half the time so it's it's phenomenal
simon stevens of the nhs i think at the
press conference yesterday talked about
doubling the rate from where we are
today but
it can go higher than that can't it
i think the thing that people have to
recognize is if you keep pushing the
system too hard something might break
and then you've got a problem so
i think the rate we're doing at the
moment is getting us to the right place
and i don't think we should push it too
hard we should push it
as hard as we can along with the supply
that we can push as hard
if we say to the manufacturers double
your output to us next week
they might push their system and it
might break so we've got to do it
sensibly i always say that you know what
we've done here is we've built something
like we built a formula one car that can
go 300 miles an hour
i wouldn't like to be the person that
just sat in it and put the foot to the
floor
because if it's never been tested before
it may not work or it may do something
really horrible
so let's keep pushing we'll keep pushing
the numbers up we'll keep pushing
numbers of vaccines that we get
into the system up we'll keep pushing
the speed of vaccination up but but we
shouldn't give people the expectation
this is something simple to do it's
very complicated and we've done it
amazingly well so far and we'll keep
doing it well and we'll push as hard as
we can
what could a break look like you said it
could you could break the process just
spell out what you mean by that
well if you if you're trying to
manufacture something and you try and
increase the rate of it maybe it goes
one step too far and it
stops working and then you've got to
start again so you've got a break you
know so
while it while something's working don't
mess with it don't try and
don't try and push it too hard it's the
same you know it's when you run a
marathon you
if you if you run it five mile the first
five miles too fast you don't get to the
end
you actually break down and this is a
system
one doctor said today to me that he
regarded the current phase as a sprint
and he was
about to go into a marathon and that
marathon might last up to sort of 12
weeks or a bit more
uh which might be right
um that takes us to about may for first
doses for pretty much everybody does it
probably but the thing is
the vaccine task force was set up to
deliver vaccines
not to deploy them so it's definitely
not my
it's well above my pay grade to talk in
detail about deployment and timelines i
i'm happy to say we're confident we can
deliver the vaccines for that deployment
but it's really not
not my place and nor have i got the
detailed understanding of it
now are the vaccines made from start to
finish
in the united kingdom uh or are there
bits and pieces that we're reliant on
from overseas you'll know the political
context for that question
at one stage the european union were
threatening to introduce export blocks
and
that threat might still be on the table
can we do it all ourselves or are we
relying on either on components or
manufacturing out overseas still
well i think there's not a single thing
that's manufactured in any country in
the world that doesn't involve a
supply chain that has things from other
places and that's just a fact
the majority and the bulk of what we
make in the uk in terms of the vaccine
itself and the fill and finish of it is
in the uk
but for the astrogenic vaccine obviously
the pfizer vaccine is made in germany
um that eu threat any at any point were
you worried
by it or had were you worried at the
time and then the threat seems to have
receded a bit how did you view all of
that
export ban we were confident that what
we'd ordered we'd get and uh
whether the threat because it was at the
political level we had nothing to do
with those discussions we just carried
on doing what we were asked to do which
would deliver vaccine
i think the million dollar question is
what did the vaccine task force do
that ensure that our rate of supply is
guaranteed in the way that you talk
about so confidently
in a way that just hasn't been true with
european countries currently struggling
what was it that you did
to ensure that the uk got it right where
other countries are just a little bit
behind
i can tell you what we did i don't know
whether that was the reason it got us
ahead so
we entered into this whole process back
in
uh march of last year or may i guess we
started really getting into it
with the whole concept that we'd partner
with the pharmaceutical companies and
work with them to get
the vaccines approved so we we
established incredibly good clinical
networks in the uk
we had the uk registry which was the
first ever registry for vaccine
volunteers which got us to do trials
quicker we
we looked at manufacturing help and
places where they could manufacture in
the uk
and we worked with them in partnership
saying if you've got a block or a hole
or or a need we can help you and i think
that was the difference
that partnership became a real bond and
then
they deliver for you because you're
working together and we didn't treat
them as a
an outsider that you're just procuring
vaccine from we said let's do it
together and let's make sure that we
get vaccines not just for the uk but
help you get that development work
through as
fast as possible so that you can develop
vaccines for the rest of the world
and that was part of our mantra that
kind of high-tech manufacturing
was that something that britain was
already
a specialist in or have you had to build
that capability from the ground up
is this a novel process that um that
you've constructed
certainly not from the ground up the the
uk government had
what was called a life science
industrial strategy that's been going
for quite some time now looking at
areas where high-tech manufacturing and
high-tech science could be moved into
products
and so a lot of the components were
there it was just a matter of then
pulling them together and getting them
to work together for with a common cause
um just a couple of other subjects one
of the roles of the vaccine task force
is to help the international community
do you think that there could ever be a
situation
where the uk's extraordinary
pre-purchase some of that stock
is sold on to other countries before
everybody's had two
vaccines or is that not the right way to
look at it i think we've always felt
that
when we started there were no vaccines
and so we took a portfolio approach we
wanted to make sure that there was at
least
enough vaccine to vaccinate the uk
population
and at the point when we started
the view was maybe only one in ten
vaccine developments work so we've got
to get more than one or two
so we got eight and we've been
incredibly successful some people say
lucky that we chose a
that look like they're all going to be
approved eventually
and that means we've gotten far more
vaccine than we need
there's no doubt that vaccine will be
used and it will be used
for other citizens around the world and
we've just got to figure out a way of
doing that
but before we do both or uh before every
adult in the uk has two jabs or
is that a slightly species we definitely
want to vaccinate our own population for
it would be a bit weird to actually have
people still dying and giving their
vaccine away
are there going to be vet better
vaccines further down the track vaccines
that deliver
everything you want sterilization rather
than partial
infection reduction um and perhaps all
in one
uh jab you know is there is there even
better
coronavirus vaccine prospects there are
prospects there's nothing there that
suddenly stands out but there's no doubt
that
once we understand what these vaccines
do in depth
we will we will make better vaccines
that we'll do and many of the things
that you talk about here
to ask two questions about how we got
here um
what were the origins of the task force
the coronavirus response by the british
government wasn't
outstanding for a lot of 2020 and then
this turned out to be
the outstanding uh dimension of it um
but its origins
go back as early as april whose idea was
it how did it come into being what role
did
patrick valance boris johnson dominic
cummings playing all of it
i don't know anything about the roles of
each and play i know it was a decision
that boris picked up the phone to
kate bingham because that's on record
but i think sir patrick was
instrumental in thinking about needing a
task force we know that too
and and i think the rest is history
after that
what um judgment should be made on kate
bingham's role uh
as the founder chair of the vaccine's
task force do you think she's been hard
done by by the end
absolutely hard done by she's a goddess
she she is one of the most brilliant
people i've ever worked with
she knew what to do she made it happen
and and
of course it took a huge team the team
inside that really made it happen he's
much more than an individual
but she led it with the most amazing
energy and made it happen
and you can take nothing away from that
and one of the things i remember from
last year was that whenever they stood
up at the
podium and in private some scientists
were
far less sure that vaccines were the way
out there was talk about therapeutics
being a large part of the answer
uh there was concern that vaccines might
only work for some parts of the
population
and not others and might be far less
efficacious
was that your experience early on did
you have to fight
some scientists who were a bit more um
casting a few more
uh bits of doubt on the process and what
was the eureka moment when you realized
actually yes vaccines were going to be
the way out because they were far more
uh effective than people had realized
there was never a debate it was we've
got to get vaccines and
we just set about getting them and soon
as we started
seeing data clinical data it was looking
good and
i would say when we got our first look
at
phase one phase two data with some of
the vaccines we realized they'd chosen
the right antigen
and the data looked good enough to
actually produce something that was very
effective
and then we had to do the big trials to
prove it has there been a moment where
you've been able to deliver boris
johnson good news and see
up front the reaction not me personally
i've i've had
very little interaction with with the
prime minister i've
worked steadfastly behind the scenes if
you like um
i've spoken to some of the ministers
about the work we're doing of course
we get permission to spend the money
through the ministers so they
they make the decision so we do speak to
them but um not really there wasn't
really a moment of anything
it's all been good news i would say with
the vaccine tassels
finally if you had a message if you
having sat at now
sitting atop this extraordinary effort
that i think it's fair to say
millions of people are grateful for
what's your message to the nation who
are
benefiting from the work that you guys
have done over the last year or so
i think first of all thank you to all
the volunteers that volunteered to go in
the trials they're the most important
people in the end without them
and without those trials the rest of the
public wouldn't have wouldn't have any
vaccine
and just thank you for all the people
involved the clinicians
the clinical networks the government the
people in government
the civil servants everybody worked flat
out this was
we wanted to beat this virus and and
there was a camaraderie there right
across the nation everybody wanted it
and it was easy it was sort of easy to
work in that environment